this afternoon the oxford michigan
community is working to pick up the
pieces today after another student died
following that school shooting at a high
school the death toll now stands at four
seven others injured
this marks the 28 school shooting in the
u.s this year nancy chen has more
school shooting at oxford high school
the first 9-1-1 call was made at 12 51
pm local time over 100 more calls
followed
police officers were dispatched by 12 52
p.m and in the next two to three minutes
they had the suspect in custody a 15
year old sophomore armed with a
semi-automatic gun firing at least 12
rounds it was loaded at the time and
still contained seven rounds of
ammunition but before police cleared
sheltering students and staff video from
the school showed students inside
classrooms during those terrifying
minutes in one video students can be
seen talking to someone on the other
side of a locked door who appears to
want to enter
now we're not willing to take that risk
right now i can't hear you we're not
taking that risk right now okay
look at my bag bro
no yeah bro no he said bro he said bro
red flag
suspicious of the person on the other
side the students run out of the
classroom
to safety slow down you're fine
tate muir was one of the victims the 16
year old student athlete died on the way
to the hospital we're not going to like
hear his laugh anymore cassidy o'neill
is a junior at oxford high school she
barricaded inside a locked room with her
boyfriend and school mates this is
something you see in like movies like
this doesn't happen at oxford doesn't
happen at my school
local law enforcement and the fbi are
now sifting through social media as well
as surveillance video for clues on what
happened
nancy chen cbs news oxford michigan
the accused gunman now facing murder
terrorism and other charges